today's question comes from
chad in utah my wife has been diagnosed
with disassociative identity disorder
otherwise known as multiple
personalities
too often when she goes shopping some of
her younger identities come up and she
ends up spending money that we just
don't have
then she gets home and feels bad about
her purchases but is too ashamed to take
things back
we are in baby step 2 and working toward
getting our debts paid off but it's
going extraordinarily slow because of
this
my question is what advice would you
have to help curb the
curb the spending aside from simply
taking over the money i just don't know
what else to do
you got to simply take over the money
you got to take
the debit card out of her hands you'll
have to when she is
in what i would call when she's got her
central state when her central identity
is running the show you got to make sure
that um she turns over all of her
spending and your job is now to
go to the store you're working with
someone who's not fully well and until
she can integrate some of that and
that's a hard long process
you're going to be running the show when
it comes to the money yeah if she is
not um
if we were to if you if say someone has
dementia
as an example they are of diminished
capacity
right from a legal standpoint and so you
could take
your your grandpa into the judge
with the docs letters and say grandpa's
of diminished capacity we need to take
over and take
you know they appoint a guardian and
light them and you don't ask
someone who is of diminished capacity to
make
quality decisions for themselves right
and
uh and and so from a legal standpoint
you don't have to do that legally in
this case but uh you literally take over
someone's finances for their own good
that's right
not for your good but um because they're
not
capable of doing it in in their current
state
uh hopefully there's some work that can
be done
and this is not a permanent thing but uh
but basically you're
um she's got a mental illness
and you're caring for a a wife who has a
mental illness that's right
and i would recommend chad i recommend
you get a friend or an accountability
partner that will walk with you because
she may not be able to carry that load
right now
and that's the season y'all are in and
you may be in this road for a long time
right um this is a very very rare
disorder
um despite how much attention it gets on
tv and whatnot
and you may be in it for a while and so
get somebody you can walk along with you
that will cheer you on that will be
frustrated with you
and will help you make good decisions
but yeah this is your this is your
your road to home my man i'll give you
another one okay something as simple as
i've worked with over the years uh
uh someone who's recovering uh from a
gambling addiction
you can they can't touch money right
until they've got six months clean
and then they can only touch certain
amounts and then they gotta have another
six months clean and then they can only
touch
certain amounts and then you know when
you got two years clean we could talk
about
i'm enjoying accounts again right but
otherwise i'm just going to take care of
you
right because when you touch money you
can't do it that's right
and so it's not good for you it's not
good for us and
um so you're expecting something of her
that she does not have the
strength and capacity to deliver which
is called self-discipline that's right
and so you've got to step in and do that
very interesting let me ask you this
when i read this
um because i know nothing about this i
mean other than i
i know what this is but uh you know from
the three psych classes i had in my life
but you know but uh uh how often is
something like this
misdiagnosed significantly
massively massively true disassociative
identity disorder is super super rare
and it's just it's a splintering of your
identities it's less about you've got
different people living inside of you
and more
you've got identities usually it stems
from really significant trauma
from childhood and you've got different
identities that will rise up and take
care of different things like scary
moments and joyful moments
and there may be something around money
or stores
or responsibility that this jack's wife
reverts back and usually there's one
that's a quarterback
there's some interesting stuff man you
can look at the brain images change
uh blood pressure changes um in true
diagnostics it's
it's really bizarre but it's very it's
incredible but it's very very rare right
yeah so
um maybe not in this situation but maybe
if someone thought they had that it
could be that
it's almost like we're trying to give
something a label where i'm just
refusing to control myself occasionally
usually
if you've got it's just the younger me i
need a victim yeah
if if i would go see somebody i'd go see
two different people who diagnosed me
with this
um i would not absolutely 100 you can't
self-diagnose this
no right and sometimes dealing with
trauma
uh and i can't un-diagnose it sitting
here obviously either and that's not
what i'm trying to do in their situation
i just uh you know part of part there's
a little part of me that wonders you
know
the younger identity i just i've heard
so many people have so many excuses
over the years on why they will not
control their spending that's exactly
right
i'm not saying that's the case with her
but i just i'm always leery that's right
and again in these rare rare moments
yeah the the working together working
together means you're taking over
right yeah yeah you're just because
you're just our diminished capacity
that's right
that's different than i refuse to or it
makes me scared to win or it reminds me
when i was a kid and
that's right those are different that's
a lot of different different that's a
difference in a 10 and a two
yeah this you're talking your heart rate
changes your blood pressure
i've seen some where vocal cords reshift
some are smoking and some don't smoke i
mean it's
you're talking dramatic and it's super
rare and
like i said if if someone i love was
diagnosed with this i would be on the
phone with another doctor immediately to
get
um a completely new work up to see if
this was
with this is accurate and true very
interesting yeah yeah it probably shows
up in the movies more than in real life
way more in the movies that's right
okay yeah open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and by the way just in
case some of you misheard that
and neither one of us are saying that is
the case with chad's wife
absolutely it's just a discussion
because this kind of thing comes up
behaviors and mental illnesses and
diagnosis you know bipolar is the one i
do get a lot we get that a lot and
and that's much more frequent yeah and
we're dave we're living in a world where
you can only get reimbursed from
insurance with a diagnosis
and so there is a there is a tendency
there is an incentive to
give a diagnosis which means get labeled
get labeled
we live in a world where we overnight
literally 10 years ago we all got access
to everybody's information
without the training that goes with
deciphering some of that information and
so we all have become armchair
quarterbacks when it comes to what you
have what i have
pop psychologists and then the third is
we are all looking for a reason why
uh like we talked about in the last
segment why we can't just grind out and
do the hard
small steps that is every day and you
take all three of those together and
yeah you get
diagnosis all over the place you get
people diagnosing themselves
prescriptions issues like their tic tacs
and
then look around we got a mess right but
that doesn't undermine
there are very real psychological
challenges that people experience
absolutely they do
there's no question just we're living in
attention we're not trying to be cold in
that right now i didn't hear that at all
yeah
no i'm and i'm just saying neither one
of us are saying that about his wife
yeah
because we don't know in that situation
but if that is truly what's going on and
it sounds like it is
then yes you you cannot she cannot
handle money
until she has a level of healing past
that um and if you're you know if you
have someone that's dealing with
gambling addiction they cannot touch
money
if they're dealing with a pornography
addiction they cannot touch money matter
of fact if they're dealing with an
addiction
they just can't touch money because
addicts 100 of addicts are broke
eventually
it's the gasoline for their fire right
eventually they're going to spend money
on their thing whatever it is they're
addicted to to the point they destroy
their family and themselves
eventually there are no such thing as
rich addicts
hmm that remain rich foreign rich that's
right eventually they're going to snort
their thing
fortune away or uh you know it goes from
porn to prostitutes or whatever
and um you know gambling is pretty quick
you can run through the money with
gambling
open up your computer and you can go
through about a hundred thousand dollars
in 20 minutes
um there's always someone on the street
corner to give you some more right oh
yeah
absolutely there's a though there's a
you know the internet will hook you up
baby
and um we're now seeing the fastest
growing addiction
in our offices for financial counseling
is porn really second is gambling
because of internet access that's right
driven it through the roof